[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halallweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wir auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport ein schön guten Abend auch
von mir schauen wir auf die Themen von
heute woher kommt der Strom bei zu wenig
Wind und Sonne die Bundesregierung
einigt sich auf einen
energiereserveplan ein paar Stunden
parken mehr als 200 € Paris erhöht die
Gebühren für schwere SUV drastisch
einige deutsche Städte schauen das
Konzept interessiert
[Musik]
an Nacht der Frauen in LA bei der Grammy
Verleihung Räumen Taylor Swift und viele
ihrer Kolleginnen die topkategorien für
die besten musikalischen Leistungen
ab für den Wirtschaftsminister ist es
ein Schritt zum klimaneutralen
Stromsystem nach langem Ringen hat sich
die Bundesregierung geeinigt wie sie in
sogenannten dunkelflauten die
Energieversorgung ohne Kohlestrom
sicherstellen will dafür sollen in den
nächsten Jahren neue Gaskraftwerke
gebaut werden sie sollen dann Energie
liefern wenn keine Sonne scheint oder zu
wenig Wind weht für die Kraftwerksbauer
lohnt sich das nur weil es massive
Zuschüsse vom Start geben wird ab
2035 sollen diese Kraftwerke auf
Wasserstoff umgestellt werden Karl
Hinterleitner hat
Details in Altbach bei Stuttgart geht in
D Jahren dieses Gaskraftwerk in Betrieb
umrüstbar auf Wasserstoff genau solche
Kraftwerke stehen im Zentrum der
Strategie der Bundesregierung erstmal
begrüßen wir die Tatsache dass die
kraftwerkstrategie heute veröffentlicht
wurde das ist ein sehr wichtiger Schritt
in die richtige Richtung natürlich
verstehen wir dass es noch ein weiter
Weg ist bis zur Implementierung ein Weg
der noch über 10 Jahre dauert bis der
endgültige Umstieg auf Wasserstoff
beginnt ein langwieriger aber
notwendiger Schritt in die grüne
Transformation meint Robert habck nicht
immer scheint die Sonne und nicht immer
W der Wind und die Konsequenz ist wir
brauchen grundlastfähige Kraftwerke das
sind im Moment fossile Kraftwerke Kohle
Steinkohle also Braunkohle Steinkohle
und Gaskraftwerke und die sollen
sukzessive aus dem Markt gehen das wird
auch so kommen bis zum Sommer soll es
einen kapazitätsmechanismus geben der
finanzielle Anreize für Betreiber setzt
Bereitschaftsdienst für stromarme
Stunden vorzuhalten für die FDP ein
richtiger Weg ich bin sehr zufrieden mit
der Lösung denn die Lösung beinhaltet
einen kapazitätsmechanismus das heißt
einen günstigen Zubau von
Kraftwerkskapazitäten jetzt muss es
schnell in die Umsetzung gehen damit wir
saubere und sichere Energieversorgung
auch im Winter haben die Opposition
widerspricht die Pläne der Regierung sei
unausgegoren da bleiben alle Fragen
offen was erwartet die Investoren wie
wird ausgeschrieben wie wird das finanzi
wir haben nach wie vor keine Klarheit
die Hängepartie geht weiter mit rund 16
Milliarden Euro kosten rechnet die
Regierung für die nächsten 20 Jahre ob
das am Ende wirklich reicht ist aber
noch
offen viele Bürger Kirchen
Gewerkschaften und Arbeitgeber rufen
dieser Tage dazu auf die Demokratie zu
schützen jetzt haben sich auch
nachkommen deutscher Widerstandskämpfer
wie bonnhöfeer oder von Staufenberg zu
Wort gemeldet mit einem dringenden
Appell sie fordern Zitat der neuen
Rechten in unserem Land und europaweit
die Stirn zu bieten alle sollten sich
verantwortlich fühlen die liberale und
rechtsstaatliche Demokratie zu bewahren
und zu verteidigen auch der
Bundeskanzler warnte heute vor
Rechtsextremismus und Rassismus bei
einem Treffen mit migrantenverbänden im
Kanzleramt Frank
Buchwald Frankfurt heute abend Protest
gegen Rechtsextremismus sowie in vielen
deutschen Städten Angst um die e treibt
Tausende auf die Straße wer in der
Demokratie schläft wacht im Faschismus
auf und wir sind auf dem Weg dahin
Rassismus sollte kein kein keine Chance
in Deutschland haben ist ja auch
irgendwie total schön dass so viele
Leute da sind Emotionen und sorgen die
auf den Kanzler bewegen wir lassen nicht
zu dass Extremismus und Intoleranz
unsere Gesellschaft Spalten alle 84
Millionen Bürger und Bürger in unserem
Land haben die gleichen Rechte
alle verdienen Respekt und darum geht's
Olaf Scholz empfängt Menschen aus
bedrängten Minderheiten Vertreter von
migrantenverbänden mit dabei auch said
hashimi er gehört zu den Opfern des
rechtsextremistischen Anschlags von
Hanau vor fast genau 4 Jahren hasemi
erlitt dabei schwere Verletzungen sein
Bruder wurde getötet es ist symbolisch
sehr stark dass der Kanzler einlt
hierher ins Kanzleramt und und uns Gehör
Verleih weil ich denke gerade jetzt ist
es an der Zeit das stark zu machen
dieses Thema ein Dialog im Kanzleramt
auf
Augenhöhe mir und dem Bundeskanzler ist
es ein Anliegen dass wir nicht über Sie
sondern mit ihnen sprechen und deshalb
sind wir heute hier ein Signal auf das
viele Migranten lange gewartet
haben Deutschland ist unsere zu Hause
und niemand wird uns aus Deutschland
vertreiben das ist uns ganz ganz wichtig
Deutschland ist unsere zuhaus und wir
bleiben hier und deswegen brauchen wir
eine positiv Signal von Alleen Menschen
die hier leben Deutschland nämlich das
zeigt sich auch heute im Kanzleramt ist
für die allermeisten Einwanderer längst
Heimat
geworden der
antisemitismusbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung klein hat einen Angriff
auf einen jüdischen Studenten in Berlin
am Wochenende verurteilt sollten sich
die Anhaltspunkte für ein
antisemitisches ef der Attacke erhärten
forderte er die volle Härte des Gesetzes
und gegebenenfalls die
Exmatrikulation ein proalästinensischer
Student der Technischen Universität soll
den jüdischen Studenten krankenhausreif
geschlagen
haben seit geraumer Zeit sind die
Beziehungen zwischen Frankreich und
Deutschland nicht ganz so gut was man
schon daran sieht dass die letzten
französischen Ministerpräsidenten bei
ihren antrittsbesuchen einen Bogen um
Deutschland machten anders der neue
Premier Gabriel Atal keine vier Wochen
im Amt ist der 34-Jährige heute nach
Berlin gereist er wolle so das Gewicht
der deutschfanzösischen Freundschaft
betonen sagte er Bundeskanzler Scholz
empfing ihn mit militärischen Ehren
geplant sind Beratungen über bilaterale
europäische und wirtschaftspolitische
Themen und in diesen Minuten beginnt die
Pressekonferenz in Berlin Diana
Zimmermann warum ist dieser Besuch
wichtig gerade
jetzt der Besuch ist natürlich wichtig
weil es der Antrittsbesuch des neuen
französischen premier ist das Mini
macron wie er auch genannt wird des
sprachus des französischen Präsidenten
zwischen ihm und Olaf Scholz sind die
Beziehungen nicht besonders gut
vorangekommen aber sie sind natürlich
wesentlich auch deswegen weil es so
viele gemeinsame Projekte gemeinsame
sorgen gibt da ist einmal die Sorge vor
dem Erstarken der Rechtspopulisten
gerade im Jahr der Europawahl da sind
massive bauernproteste auch Frankreich
hat damit zu kämpfen und da ist
natürlich die Sorge um die Sicherheit
Europa und die Frage wie geht es weiter
mit der Ukraine Olaf Scholz hat in der
Vergangenheit Frankreich mehrfach
ermahnt mehr zu tun für die Ukraine
Gabriel Atal hat das hier gerade
zurückgewiesen die
Hilfen Frankreichs an die Ukraine seinen
massiv und von sehr großer Qualität
wichtig ist es beiden auch an die USA zu
signalisieren wir werden in unserer
Unterstützung für die Ukraine nicht
nachlassen das ist eine Botschaft die
Olaf Scholz wenn er am Donnerstag nach
Washington reist auch an Präsident Joe
Biden mitnehmen möchte Diana Zimmermann
live aus Berlin danke für diese
Eindrücke der nächste Streik steht an
übermorgen trifft es wohl mehr als
100.000 Flugreisende die Gewerkschaft
werdi hat das Bodenpersonal der
lufthanser zum Arbeitskampf aufgerufen
betroffen sind die Standorte Frankfurt
am Main München Hamburg Berlin und
Düsseldorf von Mittwoch 4 Uhr bis
Donnerstag Morgen 10 bis 20% der Flüge
sollen Lauf laut lufthanser aber
durchgeführt werden werdi fordert für
knapp 25 000 Angestellte 12,5% mehr
Gehalt mindestens aber 500 € monatlich
was machen Fluggäste die vom Streik kalt
erwischt werden Antworten darauf finden
Sie in unserer ZDF heute App etwa was
konkret am Flughafen zu tun ist wann es
eine Entschädigung gibt und wer die
jeweiligen Ansprechpartner
sind Paris wird ab September die
Parkgebühren für schwere SUVs drastisch
erhöhen bei einer Bürgerbefragung haben
zwar nicht viele mitgemacht aber die
Mehrheit war dafür 18 statt bisher 6 €
für die erste Stunde zu verlangen 6
Stunden Kosten sogar 225 €. das soll die
sperrigen SUVs aus der Innenstadt
verdrängen und die Luft verbessern auch
in deutschen Kommunen ist das ein Thema
wie Jürgen kill berichtet sie sind
schwer sie sind groß und Sie werden
immer mehr der Trend ist ungebrochen
jedes dritte neue Auto in Deutschland
ist ein SUV allein im vergangenen Jahr
sind mehr als
855 000 neu zugelassen worden schon
schick von draußen aber hat bestimmt
auch seine umweltlichen Nachteile das
Autos meh größer werden mehr Platz
einnehmen und auch mehr verbrauchen ist
durchaus ein Problem für die Stadt denn
alle müssen auch irgendwo parken in
tübigen gibt es schon Sondertarife für
SUV anwohnerpken für Fahrzeuge bis 1,8
Tonnen 120 € im Jahr für die schwereren
Karossen werden 180 fällig das ärgert
einige finde ich nicht in Ordnung
verstöß gegen Gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz
ein Auto kann ich ausschlaggebenend sein
für das was ich bezahlen muss parkpreis
nach Gewicht in Tübingen und bald auch
in Paris der adhc findet das nicht ideal
es ist tatsächlich nicht so wenn man auf
die Datenbanken schaut dass nur große
Autos die augenscheinlich schwer sind
über diese 1,6 Tonnen fallen es gibt
auch normale Autos die Familien
vielleicht fahren wie den VW Caddy der
eben über dieser Grenze liegt in
Hannover fürchtet man deswegen auch
klagen man sucht eine Lösung die
autogröße könnte hier bald über den
parkpreis entscheiden ob es nach Fläche
Länge oder wie eine fre Bepreisung
letztendlich aussehen kann das muss dann
entlang dieser rechtlichen Möglichkeiten
diskutiert werden und dann auch
politisch beschlossen werden ganz klar
ist aber dass wir nach Verbrauch der
Fläche auch eine andere Bepreisung
brauchen noch gibt es in Deutschland nur
wenige konkrete Pläne SUV Fahrer
zusätzlich zur Kasse zu bitten die
cheidung von Paris befeuert aber auch
hierzulande die Diskussion über den
Stadtverkehr der
Zukunft in Chile wird mit jedem Tag
deutlicher welche katastrophalen Folgen
die dort lodernen Waldbrände haben
Helfer finden in den
Katastrophengebieten immer mehr Tote
besonders schlimm ist die Lage in der
Küstenregion mit den Städten Wien Delmar
und
walparaiso mindestens 112 Todesopfer
sind bestätigt fast 400 Menschen gelten
noch als vermisst
rer es sind ganze Straßenzüge die das
Feuer verschlungen hat im beliebten
Ferienort vin del Mar an der Küste
westlich der Hauptstadt Santiago selbst
bei Tageslicht ist das Ausmaß der
verheerenden Brände die seit Tagen in
Chile wüten kaum abzusehen die Zahl der
Toten und Vermissten steigt noch immer
an viele der Überlebenden können kaum
fassen was ihnen passiert
ist das Feuer war auf der anderen Seite
und in 10 15 Minuten war es hier überall
schlugen Flammen aus dem Boden Glut
Feuer überall wir konnten die Hitze
nicht mehr
aushalten der Rauch der ganze Himmel
wurde schwarz alles war verbrannt der
Wind war wie ein Tornado es war wie in
der
Hölle die Regierung hat schnelle Hilfe
versprochen und eine nächtliche
Ausgangssperre verhängt um Plünderungen
zu vermeiden viele stehen vor dem
Nichts hier stand meine Küche da hat ich
auch eine Waschmaschine
da war das Badezimmer mit Dusche und
Toilette ein Teil der Brände konnte die
Feuerwehr inzwischen unter Kontrolle
bringen dafür werden aus weiter
südlichen Regionen neue Feuer gemeldet
die Behörden vermuten teilweise
Brandstiftung als Auslöser der
Brände es gibt ganz klare Anzeichen
dafür dass Absicht dahinter steckt es
kann kein Zufall sein es kann nicht sein
dass vier Feuer zur selben Zeit von
selbst oder zufällig
entstehen die Ermittlungen laufen
Präsident borit hat eine zweitägige
Staatstrauer
angeordnet die Angriffe jemenitischer
hui Milizen auf Containerschiffe im
Roten Meer ziehen seit Wochen die
internationale Aufmerksamkeit auf sich
nur noch selten richtet sich der Blick
auf die Situation in dem vom Bürgerkrieg
geschundenen Land selbst dort herrscht
eine der weltweit schlimmsten
Hungerkrisen 20 Millionen Menschen in
dem Land sind dringend auf nahrungshilfe
angewiesen besonders dramatisch ist die
Situation in der von den hui
kontrollierten Region dort leben 70 bis
80% der Bevölkerung und jetzt zieht sich
auch noch das Welternährungsprogramm aus
dem Land zurück goline
atai fast 5 Millionen vertriebene hat
der Krieg im Jemen hinterlassen immer
noch kommen neue dazu in einem der
größten Zeltcamps im Nordjemen ist die
Stimmung gereizt die Menschen
wütend jetzt bekommen wir nicht einmal
mehr die nahrungsmitthilen aus dem
Ausland wir haben kein Essen kein Wasser
kein Haus nur den kalten Erdboden es
gibt keine Hoffnung für unsere
Kinder wir erfahren nicht nur fällt das
Spendenaufkommen für den Jemen immer
geringer aus das Welternährungsprogramm
hat den größten Teil seiner Hilfe für
das huthi Gebiet vorerst ausgesetzt denn
die UN werfen den huis vor
internationale Hilfe nur an ihre
politischen Günstlinge zu verteilen
nicht an die Bedürftigsten his Helfer
entführen ist ebenfalls gängige Praxis
zuletzt starb ein Mitarbeiter von Save
the Children in einem huthi
Gefängnis die Jemeniten wollen dass die
internationale Gemeinschaft die his zur
Verantwortung zieht für die Manipulation
die Ausbeutung die Verhinderung
internationaler humanitärer Hilfe wir
menschenrechtle sehen wie dadurch die
his die Bevölkerung als Geiseln
halten
eine Klinik für unterenährte Kinder im
hui Gebiet ohne die Hilfsorganisation
Ärzte ohne Grenzen wäre hier gar keine
Versorgung möglich immer mehr Fälle
würden eingeliefert berichten
Ärzte gerade kam noch diese Meldung aus
London König Charles II ist an Krebs
erkrankt und wird entsprechend behandelt
um welche Form von Krebs es sich handelt
wurde nicht bekannt
gegeben jetzt zum Urteil in einem
Prozess der die Öffentlichkeit jahrelang
Beschäftigte der Rapper Bushido gegen
seinen Ex-Manager Arafat Abu schakr der
habe laut Anklage Bushido zur Zahlung
von Millionenbeträgen erpressen wollen
dem folgte das Gericht zwar nicht
verurteilte abuschakre aber zu einer
Geldstrafe von 81 000 € Grund er hatte
vertrauliche Gespräche zwischen den
beiden heimlich aufgezeichnet Bushido
und apusakre waren lange
Geschäftspartner bevor vor der Rapper
die Verbindung 2018
auflöste wer in der Musikbranche
international Rang und Namen hat war
gestern in Los Angeles bei den Grammy
Awards ein großer Abend vor allem für
Frauen allein in der Kategorie Album des
Jahres waren sieben von acht nominierten
Frauen und gewonnen
hat Taylor Swift zum vierten Mal ein
goldenes gramophon für ein Album damit
bricht sie den Rekord von musiklegend
sie hatte allen Grund zum
Feiern mit Midnight räumte Taylor Swift
den begehrten preisalbum des Jahres ab
zum vierten Mal das hat bisher noch kein
Künstler
geschafft dieser Preis bellohnt meine
Arbeit und alles was ich will ist damit
weitermachen ich liebe es das
Produzieren macht mich
glücklich esgesam ein Abend der Frauen
von C eine eindrückliche
Performance unter anderem erhielt die
Soulsängerin den Award bester R&B
Song ihr versteht das vielleicht nicht
ich musste einen sehr weiten Weg gehen
und kann nicht glauben dass das hier
gerade
passiert mit ihrem Barbie Hit what was I
made for bekam Billy eish den gramy für
den Song des
Jahres
[Musik]
die Auszeichnung Aufnahme des Jahres
ging an Miley Cyrus für
[Musik]
flowers und Taylor Swift hatte noch eine
überraschungsankündigung im
Gepäck mein brandneues Album wird am 19
April rauskommen
es heißt the tortured POS
[Applaus]
Department und wer weiß vielleicht wird
uns dieser Titel ja wieder begegnen bei
den Grammys
2025 und jetzt englischer Fußball
gestern Abend das Spitzenspiel Arsenal
gegen Liverpool Norbert ja und da haben
die Londoner dem FC mit Trainer Jürgen
kllopp die erste Saison Niederlage in
der Premier League seit September
beschört Liverpool bleibt zwar
Tabellenführer das Titelrennen aber
jetzt wieder so richtig
spannend auch die die zu den besten der
Welt gehören erwischen mal einen
schlechten Tag natürlich hätten wir hier
gerne gewonnen aber über 90 Minuten
waren wir einfach nicht gut genug
Arsenal in den roten Trikots besonders
in der ersten Hälfte spielbestimmend
bereits nach 14 Minuten das 1:0 durch
Saka quasi mit dem pausenf kam es zu
diesem Slapstick Eigentor von Arsenals
Gabriel 1 Z1 nach dem Seitenwechsel
revangierte sich Liverpool mit diesem
kapitalen abwehrbock Martinelli mit dem
erneuten Führungstreffer für Arsenal und
in der Nachspielzeit Liverpool nur noch
zu Zeeh vollendete Trossin zum 3:1
Endstand durch diesen Sieg verkürzte
Arsenal den Abstand auf Tabellenführer
Liverpool auf zwei
Punkte ja und ein Topduell das gibt's
morgen auch hier zu Lande nämlich im DFB
Pokal der trifft im Viertelfinale der
Bundesliga Spitzenreiter aus Leverkusen
auf die Überraschungsmannschaft der sich
den tabellenritten aus
Stuttgart noch 14 Saisonspiele in der
Bundesliga aber nur drei im DFB Pokal
auch in Leverkusen weiß man welcher
Titel schneller geht so es ist die kurze
Weg im Pokal wir s zwei Spiel von vom
Finale aber morgen ist ist eine große
Herausforderung die zuletzt
erfolgreichen Stuttgarter könnten sich
den reihenländern in den kurzen Weg
stellen zumal Torjäger ser girassi vom
Afrika Cup wieder zurück ist wenn auch
mit Magen Darm Problemen da müssen wir
jetzt einfach abwarten was da rauskommt
und dann werde ich noch mal mit ihm
sprechen von Angesicht zu Angesicht und
dann wird wird eine gemeinsame
Entscheidung getroffen im letzten Jahr
kam der VfB bis ins Halbfinale da war
Leverkusen schon längst raus im DFB
Pokal ja und das letzte viertelf
Finalspiel danach Mittwoch drittigist
sbrücken gegen Gladbach bei uns in ZDF
live zu sehen danke
schön windig und regnerisch im Norden
sonnig und mild im Süden das ist das
Wetter in Kurzform Katja horneffer wird
gleich etwas
ausführlicher das heute journal um : mit
Dunja Hayali wir sagen danke und tschüss
und bis morgen wenn Sie mögen einen
schönen Abend
[Musik]
noch guten Abend und herzlich willkommen
zu einer wetterwoche in der sich Winter
und Frühling miteinander messen das
konnten sie schon heute bemerken denn
auf hindensee lagen die
Höchsttemperaturen nur bei
5,3° in Garmisch waren es dagegen
17,4°. jetzt in Nacht sinken die Werte
hier am Alpenrand auf 2 oder 1° deutlich
milder bleibt die Nacht am niederrein
mit 9° denn auch heute Nacht ziehen über
Norddeutschland die regenwolkenin Weg im
Süden ist es dagegen klar und diese
wetterzweiteilung begleitet uns auch
durch den Tag im Süden gibt's morgen
also viel Sonnenschein und über
Norddeutschland ziehen die Regenwolken
hinweg bei einem starken zum Teil sogar
stürmischen Wind aus westsüdwestlichen
Richtungen an der Nordsee gibt's auch
stromböhen die Höchsttemperaturen morgen
liegen meist bei 7 bis 12° noch etwas
milder wird es im östlichen Bayern mit
15°. am Mittwoch kann es dann für etwas
Schneeregen hier in den nördlichen
Mittelgebirgen reichen und am Donnerstag
sollten Sie sich auf eine vielleicht
sogar geschlossene Schneedecke in Nord
Deutschland einstellen da wird's dann
also auch schon wieder glatt auf den
Straßen und die Temperatur Gegensätze
verschärfen sich guten Abend